what else is new
um
i mean there's
there's so much going on dude yeah dude
have you heard about ios 16 oh
what's going on with that oh
who [ __ ] cares
that's what you weren't watching the
live stream from wwdc no no i oh
definitely i did you did so what was
your favorite part what was your
favorite part the whole thing i was just
clapping the whole time yeah yeah
how do we still give a [ __ ] about any
technology
that's a good question
that's a good question
yeah that's it you're just mic drop
who [ __ ] like users can now who [ __ ] who
cares who [ __ ] cares
their phones they do a lot of things
whatever yeah i don't think there's been
a single good feature no in the last 10
years yeah
what's been a good feature that you
liked stickers
you know that's it that's oh no no i i
you know what i like that new emoji that
blows smoke that's like whoo i like that
one okay that's a good feature
that's it that's a little picture yeah
that's the only one
i like the little picture yeah do you
remember how like when the i was going
through like organizing my [ __ ]
yesterday and i was like going through
the you know the
one box
of important [ __ ]
do you do you have the same box i have a
shoe box it's just i've had it for 20
years
just everything since i or 10 years i
guess everything since i you know moved
out of my house and went to college yeah
14 years
and it's just that one box is everything
that's like important every metal i get
from a marathon or something i put in
that one box but i was going through
that one box yesterday and i had the the
first iphone was in there oh sick what'd
you do with it
nothing i just looked at it held it yeah
but it's just incredible like the
feeling i got when i looked at it and i
was like god this unlocked just like a
whole world
it's actually really i think the
funniest part about technology is how
wildly depressed
all of gen z will be in about three
years
they've done everything yeah you know
like all the apps and [ __ ] they have
that like expedite everything for them
how to make like
their every gen z kid is doing they
they're everything right i'm a director
i'm a music artist i mean this is
because they have tutorials they can
just do everything
they're going to hit 23 and be like
there is literally nothing left except
opioids
jesus christ
they will have done everything yeah yeah
you know i went through like a yeat
period i was just like rapping on yi
type beats i was putting on little
shells and [ __ ] it was whatever yeah
then i pivoted to drop shipping and like
i made a bag but like i don't want to do
that for the rest of my life and and
what kind of like
technological advancements do they get
it's web 3 which is already everything's
been done before they're just redoing it
on the blockchain it's nothing new right
for us it was like the internet
everything unlocked this whole world of
like oh my god wait there's you can get
info yeah whenever and you can call
people and whatever that was everything
was new you couldn't do that before yeah
how to build a bomb exactly
and now it's just like
that was like the big thing remember
that like
googling how to build a bomb
that was like the risk
everyone did that in high school right i
don't
the big thing what do you mean the big
thing
that was like the big thing
for you maybe it was a big thing when it
blew up
no i remember that being like uh
the at least in junior high in high
school it was like the funny risky thing
to look up it's no i remember there was
like a
pdf or something wasn't there yeah it
was like it was like something yeah it
was like the anarchist cookbook yes yes
yes yes
nice luke you're on a [ __ ] list the
anarchist cookbook is out of nowhere all
right man the anarchist cookbook yeah we
feel safe on this [ __ ]
yeah my favorite part was yeah yeah
which edition do you guys speak of
what there's a there's multiple yeah
no but that's what i mean it's like we
went from
we went from like reading books
and that's it
and playing outside to to oh now you can
go all you got to do is type like a
sentence into a thing and you can learn
how to build a bomb yeah that's an
incredible leap yeah now it's like what
is it now it's now oh ios 16 will allow
users to edit messages
i'm already editing messages on my
secure chat app that's connected to the
blockchain i learned about it through
ticktalk i found this super secret
discord i got an invite to this app
they're just doing
that's that's the funny part they're
they're doing too much
also it just makes some of these things
just look behind
yeah you know like some of these ios
updates it's like where was this like
five years ago yeah but what else can
ios 16 do yeah let's go through some
more features maybe it drains more
battery life unsend text messages sick
dude
whoa
yeah that seems really cool is that it
oh that's
that's the cool part play that video
three of the most highly requested
features to messages
first have you ever sent a message only
to immediately no you're alive
that's every tick tock have you ever
sent a message nope
[Laughter]
you're sent a message nope and it's a
18 year old deadlifting 605. yeah
you seen that kid
no
shans.bruh
yeah scroll down a little bit
that one bottom left that girl's face
have you ever gotten a snapchat from a
girl
never
never a gym
and he's rowing 405. holy [ __ ] yeah okay
now get out of this now let's go to the
one with no audio so we don't get
copyright claimed go to the one uh
next row up all the way to the right
yeah 405 and just yank
this is what i mean when i say i work
out in like other states and i see kids
like him in the gym i'm like i'm just
gonna buy a [ __ ]
gatling gun yeah
i wanted to feel how heavy it was
turns out it wasn't that heavy yeah
turns out i can do 800 yeah so shout out
to shans bro yeah wow ios 16 is wild
yeah
yeah
have you ever sent a message never never
i jim
yeah what other features we got let's
get the other two features you know end
it on a high note
because now you could basically edit any
messages
well good news now you have undo sen
did you send a weird desperate message
and yeah she ghosted you well good news
did you double text
now you can i'm a [ __ ] loser
did you send a super [ __ ] message
this is yeah
every dude down horrific is like thank
god yeah yeah thank god recall a recent
misfire and finally you can now mark any
thread as unread a perfect tool if you
don't have time to respond in the moment
and want to be sure to come back to a
message later
all of these features are just
enabling people to not have commitment
yeah if you're gonna double text like
just
it's done i think
double texting
is one of those things that you need to
go through that yeah you shouldn't have
the ability to retract it yeah you need
to like hold that [ __ ] l and
experience that yeah yeah how are you
supposed to learn from your mistakes
yeah if you can just undo your mistakes
yeah
yeah you live
you're more and more that's deep it is
deep
there's levels to that yeah
you know
that's something you thought of in the
bahamas yeah yeah